Vsauce!
Kevin here.
For almost three thousand years the cure-all
for any medical ailment was bleeding.
It was believed that being sick was due to
an imbalance of the four humors: blood, phlegm,
black bile and yellow bile.
So whether someone had a seizure or a fever
- they thought it was due to having too much
blood and therefore had to remove some by
cutting at the elbow or letting leeches suck
it out.
George Washington died after half of his blood
was removed as treatment for a severe sore
throat.
Trepanning is the oldest surgical procedure
we have archaeological evidence of and it
consists of drilling a hole in the skull.
It was often performed for medical purposes
to cure migraines, epileptic seizures, and
even mental disorders by means of releasing
the evil spirits trapped in the head.
In the 60s Dutchman Bart Hughes performed
self-trepanation using an electric drill and
advocated others to do the same in order to
increase the volume of brainblood and reach
a higher state of consciousness - a claim
to which the scientific community said umm.
No.
The enema has also been around for thousands
of years - being mentioned in detail on Ancient
Egyptian Papyrus circa 1600 BC.
The rectal purge was performed using hollowed
out animal bones attached to liquid-filled
gourds and were purported to cure everything
from the common cold and allergies to headaches.
17th Century France became so obsessed with
internal cleansing some had three or four
enemas a day and King Louis XIV is said to
have had thousands.
Even receiving enemas while hanging out with
his buddies.
When the Great Plague of London hit in 1665,
attempted remedies included tobacco smoke
which led to children being instructed to
smoke in schoolrooms to passing gas in a jar
and then smelling it - because they believed
foul smells caused the plague, and they could
fight it off with foul smells of their own.
And as always - thanks for watching!